what is BD so when they're just saying
BD they're saying literally the length
of segment BD so they're saying the
length from B point B to point D and B
is sitting here at negative 2 D here's
at 5 so you're looking at really the
distance between negative 2 & 5 so you
literally could just say well that's
going to be 5 that's kind of our
endpoint minus negative 2 so 5 minus
negative 2 is the same thing as 5 plus 2
or 7 another way you could literally
just count it out count out the distance
you go 1 2 to get to 0 3 4 5 6 7 to get
all the way to 5 or you could say look I
got to get I got to go to to the right
just to get I got to go to to the right
just to get to 0 and I got to go 5 more
to the right to get to D so that's going
to be 7 let's do a couple more what is
BD again well here we're going from 1 to
4 the distance between 1 & 4 is 3 and
then let's do one more what is a D so a
is it negative 5 D is all the way at 4
so we're going from negative 5 to 0
which is 5 and then we're going to go
for more 5 plus 4 is 9 or you could say
hey look we start at negative 5 we end
up at 4 4 minus negative 5 is the same
thing as 4 plus 5 which is 9